on a calé l'ambiance sur place
écoutez grégory très bonne ambiance un
cortège qui c'est qui a démarré près
d'eux barbes et qui s'étaient lancés
dans les rues de paris pour ensuite a
terminé à nation n'y est pas encore y
vont en tout cas beaucoup de bonne
ambiance
beaucoup de ferveur beaucoup de
solidarité beaucoup de slogans hostiles
au gouvernement israélien pour dire non
à cette annexion et regarder sur ces
images plusieurs centaines de
manifestants voire peut-être même plus
d'un millier en tout cas beaucoup
d'associatifs beaucoup de citoyens
simplement venir venu ici soutenir la
palestine je vous propose de les écouter
elle est à nous parler on doit pas
garder le 6 nov
le non-dit sera pas libre sans la
liberté du peuple palestinien
tout ce qu'on appelle là maintenant la
palestine la cisjordanie où tout ça ce
sera perdu et on sera fragmenté plus de
plus en plus est après tout ce qu'on
quand ça devient légal au quand ça
devient annick seo je sais pas par la
loi et israéliens ça va être très
difficile après de faire un retour ça
fait très longtemps qu'on demande des
sanctions en direction du régime
d'apartheid israélien parce que c'est le
seul moyen aujourd'hui de changer la
donne sur le terrain à l'heure où le
gouvernement netanyahu a annoncé
l'annexion des territoires palestiniens
occupés
eh bien nous on dit qu'il faut se
mobiliser et en se mobilisant notamment
à travers la campagne bds pour imposer
une pression des pressions sur le régime
d'apartheid israélien
le projet d'annexion d'une grosse partie
de la cisjordanie
c'est une étape supplémentaire très
importante dans la politique de
dépossession du peuple palestinien par
rapport à ça il est hors de question
pour des gens qui sont rattachés à
l'indépendance des peuples à l'égalité
des droits à la justice enfin la dignité
il est hors de question de laisser
passer ça plusieurs associations et
simples citoyens qui dénoncent cette
future élection qui sera annoncé en tout
cas le 1er juillet par benyamin
nétanyahou et beaucoup de manifestants
ont aussi dénoncé
mutisme de beaucoup de grandes
puissances de pays occidentaux notamment
de l'union européenne cette
manifestation pour le moment elles se
passent dans de très bonnes conditions
avec un dispositif policier assez
important vous le voyez peut-être sur
ces images des forces de l'ordre qui
quadrillent qui cadrent ce rassemblement
ici on se trouve actuellement la près de
république et cette manifestation elle
touchera à sa fin à la nation merci mon
âme ou dès lors en direct donc de cette
manifestation dans les rues de paris